[Music]
good evening and welcome to the running
commentary our top story this week as
ever is that Simon is a top-heavy
chunga's who is also slow we now receive
an update on the Just Giving page for
Simon's double half marathon running
attempt son Clark reports so as of today
which is the seventh of January the
total raised for the just giving for
running is the target was 500 and I said
that if we reach a thousand pounds I
will run in a costume I thought that
that was a big stretch and after just a
couple of days we are at 1,200 pounds
raised which is incredible like
absolutely incredible amount of money to
be giving to charity so I thought I
would do a video diary of the training
to kind of you know show you what I've
been up to and you know make sure that
I'm actually ready because now there's a
lot of pressure there's a lot of money
there's a lot of pressure for me to you
know really really do this well so I now
for today need to do a I'm looking at my
schedule 6 mile run you know it's kind
of funny
all of these hills which last time I did
this route it seemed gigantic and
incredibly painful after the Mammoth's
run I did back home in Bristol
easy barely notice there there Oh
okay so interestingly despite the fact I
was trying to go to reasonably steady
pace and not go too fast that was
actually the fastest but I've done that
route and like all of the segments on
strauber on that route so so this is the
schedule that I have been training with
these are actually pixel girls and
annotations then they don't mind what I
did today was a midweek run in week six
six I've not been I've been away I've
been away which is actually where I've
not been following this terribly well
for the past couple of days for the most
part we've been pretty good at the start
where you take Monday's off you then do
three runs in the middle of the week
which are varying lengths but kind of
mid-range like starting off with 5k
going up to 10k kind of at the most
then you take Friday off then you do a
three-mile run on a Saturday which is
perfect we both do Park run and then you
do your long run on Sunday starting with
five miles working your way up to 11
miles last week I didn't get a chance to
do one because I was away I was in
London and I just didn't have anywhere
to run and so I ran on Monday this week
in Bristol which was cold and incredibly
hilly the big run this week was a real
slog it was weird actually because I
hated bits of it I hate to the bit where
it was a lot of uphill but I loved when
it got back on the flat I kind of
understood why people do this just
recreationally why people just go for
ten-mile runs because they like doing it
I mean I've got the right music on you
just feel your stride lengthen you're in
a really good headspace your body's
moving like a well-oiled machine just it
felt great so I actually really quite
enjoyed my long run this week and I'm
actually secretly kind of looking
forward to my 10-mile one which is going
to be when I'm away this weekend because
I'm always away at the moment in Oxford
I'm not too fussed about sticking to
this religiously I feel like as long as
we do a couple of mid-range runs in the
week just to keep the muscles ticking
over
and then I 10 generally I'm not worried
about speed for any of these runs I'm
just worried about getting the distance
in and then on Saturday I am kind of
going to speed a little bit but at the
same time I know I've got to do a big
run on the Sunday that's the most
important one it's just getting
psychologically I think getting used to
the distance is the single biggest thing
so I go for speed a little bit on
Saturday and then on Sunday typically
pick saga' and I run together which
means I run at her pace which is a
between a minute and 30 seconds slower
per kilometer some why I haven't found
them so bad now I'm starting to do a
couple on my own they are becoming a bit
more taxing but feels like it's all
going well if people are enjoying these
running updates I think I might do a
couple of them because I can then take
the Adsense that these videos generate
which is going to be not very many a
couple of thousand dollars maybe in
total and I can then add that to the
total so I might do a couple more of
these if people don't find them
obnoxious especially if people find them
useful if you have any questions about
how I've been preparing like other
aspects like I don't know stretching
diet finding roots though a few things I
could talk about goodness things there
are tons of youtubers who somehow find a
way of filling out 10 minutes every week
by talking about the same old nonsense
week after week so I can probably do
that but yeah if you think you watch
something like that let me know and I
can do more of these and we can raise
more money for charity which is
ultimately the point in lighter news
Simon went for several runs this week
some of which hurt and some of which
hurt a lot Simon Clarke reports okay so
that's they have work done and now go
outside and run four miles in the dark
it looks windy as balls but I'm hoping
it isn't actually as bad as it looks
nope this is much worse than it looks
oh my god well that was one of the best
runs in terms of athletic performance of
my life okay so that wasn't planned but
that was the fastest four miles I've
ever run but also the fastest kilometer
and 500 meters and a bunch of other
distance time records Bethany started
way too fast so apparently the
conditions are if anything help if
there's like her horrible conditions I
do better seemingly but that was too
fast and that was irresponsible and my
legs are cramping up right now so I'm
gonna stretch and put DP ah and take
tomorrow off I'm not doing Park run
because we've got a very long run to do
on Sunday but not here that's it for
this week's running commentary thank you
very much for joining us we will be back
next week with further updates on how
much money Simon has raised and how much
pain his legs are in good evening oh wow
yeah
oh man if deep heat wants to sponsor me
that would be amazing huh